hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
chapter 3 of john stuart mills on
liberty is
titled of individuality as
one of the elements of well-being
and so when we see that we might want to
ask
great what is this individuality that
you're talking about
what does it include what does it
encompass what
is its scope so this is a central
question
and you know he starts out early on
saying
that individuality should assert itself
where not the person's own character but
the tradition or customs of other people
are the rule of conduct
there is wanting one of the principal
ingredients of human happiness
and quite the chief ingredient of
individual and social progress
so that makes individuality sound like
something
like flowing out of our own
character who you he'll use words like
spontaneity
a little bit later or originality and
that is indeed part of it but there's so
much
more to individuality the way that
mill is thinking about it
he talks about it as being connected
with
these following things civilization
instruction education and
culture and there what we're seeing is
something that goes
definitely beyond the scope of just
the individual and individuals
something that we would think would be
binding them together
or you know some overarching
whatever we want to call it principle of
community
and continuity consider instruction
and education those are often provided
by one generation to another we can say
something
even more sweeping for culture
or civilization and mill thinks
that individuality nevertheless
actually plays a really important role
in this he says
if it were felt that the free
development of individuality
is one of the leading essentials of
well-being that it is not
only a coordinate element
with all that is designated by these
terms civilization instruction education
and culture but is itself a necessary
part
and condition of all these things and
then he goes on with that
so he's saying that not only is
individuality an element in in these
even a coordinating element right
something on the same
level but rather than individuality
itself
of the human being of human beings since
he's a pluralist about
individuality is going to provide
a kind of basis for
these and he's not just thinking he's a
utilitarian he's not just thinking of
some sort of aggregate he's saying that
real
individuality in real people
plays a role in the development and the
ongoing
fertility or relevancy
of these things as a matter of fact when
civilization or
culture or education becomes just a
matter of going through the paces and
imitation that ape-like faculty as he
calls it
they lose something of their meaning
just as much
so as was the case earlier in chapter
two
with truths that are merely memorized
from teachers and books
and not actually thought through and
lived through so this is a
quite an important point going on a
little bit further we can get some
specification and he brings up
um this this philosopher william von
humboldt
who says that the end of man or that
which is prescribed by eternal
or immutable dictates of reason and not
suggested by
vague and transient desires is the
highest
and most harmonious development of his
powers
to a complete and consistent whole
and so what does this mean so the end or
or the goal
the purpose is the develop the highest
and most harmonious development of
powers
to a complete and consistent whole this
doesn't mean
just developing each thing as if it was
a set of role-playing
stats like you know i'm going to jack up
my strength
and my dexterity and my wisdom all of
them to 18 or 20 or 25 or whatever
whatever you're playing right there has
to be coordination there has to be
integration there has to be harmonious
as he says
and consistency involved in this
so our harmonious development they work
together
consistent whole we are that whole
as human beings so you know this is kind
of similar to earlier
notions of human perfection or
fulfillment when you see perfection here
don't think of like ticking off boxes
but think instead of realization of
what human nature is really capable of
the realization
of capacities or possibilities doing so
means uniting them together and this
would be part of the development of
individuality this is what we're
aiming at according to mill
who's taking this from fond humboldt
he could have taken it from many others
as well mary wollstonecraft for example
so he talks here about several different
things
that are connected with us he says that
here we go
this is the object towards which every
human being must ceaselessly direct his
efforts and on which
especially those who designed to
influence their fellow men must
ever keep their eyes is the
individuality of
power and development right so capacity
and the development of that capacity
that for this there are two
requisites freedom and variety of
situations
let's pause on that for a moment it's
not just if you want to develop
individuality that you got to let people
be free to make their own mistakes and
try things on and
there's a range of different
possibilities rather than just
this is the way things are done right
there have to be a variety of situations
again
mill is a pluralist when it comes to
these matters he thinks that a society
in which there are a lot of live
options that people can try out or the
capacity to make their own
option is needed for this
and he goes on a little bit further and
says that
from these the union that from the union
of these
uh freedom variety of situations power
and development
arise what individual vigor
and manifold diversity so
individuality involves a kind of
development of strength and manifold
diversity he goes on a little bit and
says these combine themselves in
originality so a lot of different moving
parts here
the other main thing that we need to
think about is all right
so what in us does this
involve what are these powers that were
developing
to a complete and consistent whole and
mill
gives us a considerable amount of his
moral psychology or anthropology in this
very
chapter when he's talking about the need
to
engage in choosing in in
committing ourselves one way or another
he brings up a number of different human
faculties and capacities he tells us
that perception our capacity to take in
information from the outside world not
only about you know pure perceptual
qualities like the taste of something or
the smell of the air
or the feel of my finger against my
cheekbone or things like that but also
our other
faculties of perception as well judgment
our ability to develop new information
out of the situation that we're in to
act
as judges and say this is the case this
is not the case
discriminative feeling this is very
important
discriminative feeling isn't just
feeling like feeling sad but
feeling sad about this and not this
right or feeling uh an aesthetic
response towards something
mental activity covering a wide range of
things from imagination
memory understanding reasoning
moral preference this is also a very
important capacity for us human
beings and individuality
is going to extend to all of these
different
things i'll take for an example the
provision
of a single flower preferred to
another person in a situation we can
perceive it
we can make a judgment about it we can
have a sort of aesthetic response to it
we can think about where did this flower
come from and we can realize
through our moral sense that this is the
right thing to do or the wrong thing to
do
somebody who is giving the single dark
red rose
to somebody whose date has just gotten
up to go to the bathroom attempting to
seduce them
right bad right somebody who is bringing
that rose
at the beginning of the date uh we say
that that's right
and notice this is an aesthetic
phenomenon that we have moral
judgments about and this all enters into
the scope of individuality both of the
actor
and of the perceiver he also tells us
that our desires
and impulses and he uses the term
feelings and susceptibility in that
passage as well
are important that having our own
desires
and impulses is part of what makes us
individuals not just those provoked or
supplied to us
by for example in our time targeted
advertising
or being told that you know we need to
conform to particular
stereotypes whether these have to do
with gender or
you know ethnicity or class or things
like that you know
dudes don't cry for example well as a
matter of fact
some pretty cool dudes throughout the
history of uh
you know actual history and literature
like odysseus for example have
desires and impulses acting on our own
desires and impulses in an autonomous
way
this is part of individuality so it's
not just
all top level stuff like the intellect
and the will it's also all this other
stuff
you know the fact that i prefer
hearing this kind of music or the
experience of being in a
certain kind of prairie on a hot day and
seeing the bees and butterflies and
birds flitting around
part of my individuality perhaps not
part of
yours he also talks at another place
about
great energies guided by vigorous
reasons strong feelings by conscientious
will
this goes back to that complete and
consistent
whole we don't want to have atrophied
or underdeveloped human capacities we
want them
firing as we say on all cylinders but we
want them to be
coordinated so you're not just a you
know
jangly bag of feelings drawing you in
all sorts of different directions
never able to concentrate on a
particular project
this leads us to another thing our
social and moral
capacities mill thinks and he writes
about this in two places here in this
chapter
that if we want to develop our own
individuality
we have to understand that we exist
within
a matrix of other individualities who
have rights
who have legitimate interests that we
ought not to
transgress that there is something that
we can call justice and mill has a
brilliant analysis of justice breaking
it down into a number of different
components in
another work called utilitarianism
part five of that and he also talks
about
genius genius isn't really genius
in a full sense unless it recognizes the
legitimate needs
and interests and rights of other people
that recognizing this helps us to
develop a very important set of
capacities within us that realize
our human nature finally we should talk
about the
aesthetic he brings up this
at several different points but it's
really running throughout the entire
chapter
our appreciation for the
cultivated and developed and most likely
unfinished
and finite individuality of ourselves
and of others can be done in a way that
involves an aesthetic response where we
find it
beautiful or ugly honorable or base
maybe a work in progress is another way
of thinking about it as when we look at
some of rembrandt's sketches and we say
wow that's
that's some cool penmanship i wonder
what sort of painting
it was to develop into and so this this
aesthetic capacity
that we have is incredibly important and
is just as much part of our
individuality
as is the you know social political
moral
as is the intellectual as is the
desirous and
appetitive or impulsive in fact
you could say that the aesthetic in a
certain sense
is what brings all of these things
together
this notion of being a complete and
consistent whole
is a aesthetic value as well as
intellectual or moral so this gives you
some idea
of what mill conceives of as
falling within the scope or province
of individuality not just in general but
for all of us as individuals me
you everybody else that we encounter
you